dwyane wade claims hatred of miami
heat's big three is because they were
black men if you recall the miami heat's
big three consists of dwyane wade lebron
james chris bosh j.j reddick pointed out
that some of the hate that dwyane wade
was receiving because a group of sports
fans that are and will always be
uncomfortable with black powerful black
men
uh making decisions for themselves
taking empowerment and controlling uh
taking control their careers the women
respond i agree with you and i didn't
say that but i'm glad you said that but
we felt that way we knew that some of
the hate was because of our skin color
because of the black men uh uh deciding
taking control of their faith of our
careers because organizations will do it
quickly they will trade a dwyane wade in
a heartbeat if you're not accomplishing
what they want you to
accomplish so when we had the power when
we had the moment we took it but some of
the hate came because we were three
black guys who decided and we changed
the way that the nba probably would ever
be because of that decision so i agree
with you man 100 so what do you think
about that was that because they were
black men or
was it just because i think it's it's
kind of uh
sad that so many things circle back
around to race
and they don't need to uh that's that's
why i wrote my most recent book you know
called created equal
the painful past confusing present
and hopeful future of race in america
looking at racial issues from both ends
but
using objective evidence for instance
take the george floyd incident
it was played 24 7 incessantly
you would think that black unarmed black
men are being killed by police all the
time
we had some friends in australia we
talked to them they said yeah they
played all the time what's going on over
there
what are the real statistics
the washington post
says less than two dozen
incidents a year
with more than 50 million police
civilian encounters think about that
think about those numbers
um
so it's very rare it's a tragedy anytime
it occurs
but
recognize how the media manipulates
people
and makes you think that things are very
different than they are there was
another case
that was very similar to this
same situation police with the knee on
the neck
face on the ground saying i'm gonna die
almost no coverage why
because the victim was white
it didn't fit the narrative
who cares
these are problems
we've made enormous progress in my
lifetime
on race in this country a lot of people
aren't willing to admit that
but when i was a kid and a black person
came on television
and
they were in a non-servile role this was
a big deal you called everybody in come
and see this
now you have black admirals and generals
and ceos of fortune 500 companies and
heads of foundations
uh university presidents including ivy
league we've elected a black president
twice black vice president
you know to say that we have made
progress is absolutely ridiculous
doesn't mean we reach nirvana
and we still need to continue to make
progress but we've made a lot of
progress and we should we should
decide that we're going to build our
future on the progress
and not on the things that were
embarrassing about our country
that's powerful what you just said
you know i i can't say that i relate to
that because i'm not a black man
but uh you know being middle eastern
coming up here and you know going out
there in the insurance business while 9
11 happened i got started a day before 9
11 the worst time
for a middle eastern man from iran to
get into financial industry and uh
some people use this as an excuse saying
it's not going to help us sell to the
white man or the black man or the asian
man i said nah it's it's it's the
argument if you got a good case if
you're good at what you do if you can
take care of the client exactly you'll
be able to win at the highest level so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]